Qué pasa si llegas a los límites de un
videojuego bueno depende desde tiburones
asesinos hasta monstruos gigantes cada
juego tiene sus maneras únicas de
controlar tu impulso de idiotez y evitar
que te salgas del mapa el Far Cry 2 no
puedes alejarte mucho porque si lo haces
tu personaje sufre un poderoso ataque de
malaria y muere en el juego de Scarface
de 2006 puedes tratar de nadar pero un
tiburón te hará carnita si llegas muy
lejos en Ghost recon breakpoint los
mismos drones asesinos que te atacan a
lo largo de todo el juego comenzarán a
perseguirte hasta matarte si ven que
quieres escapar y en Dead stranding de
hecho puedes nadar bastante lejos pero
dado que el mapa está rodeado de
muchísima agua siempre terminarás
ahogándote y tendrás que revivir
mientras encuentras a un bebé en tu
estómago
Estos son solo algunos ejemplos pero en
mi canal te tengo un gran video de este
tema vas a darle un vistazo